alors je me rappelle il ya dix ans dans
les bus de montréal j'étais toujours
avec mon gros marqueur et je m'amuse à
écrire un peu partout fonky family qui
le nom d'un groupe de rap français que
j'adorais à cause de l'influencé de mes
grands frères
et puis jusqu'au jour où je rencontre un
ami qui me parle de toute la culture du
graffiti et tout ce qui se cache
derrière le tag et tout ce qui m'a dit
ces écoutes choisi toi un nom avant toi
un nom et le jeu c'est de mettre partout
dans la ville just galope insisté pas
donc j'ai décidé de garder le nom fond
qui est à partir de ce jour la vie a
complètement changé ma vision de voir
les choses ma vie ma façon de vivre ma
ville j'étais plus obligés de simplement
j'étais plus réduit à juste marcher sur
le trottoir les toits d'édifices les
building abandonner toute la ville était
devenu comme un gros terrain de jeu je
me sentais comme invincible comme un
espèce de super héros avec ce nouveau
nom funky bon jetez plus comme un super
héros avec mes notes à l'école mais bon
et je vous avoue que quand des fois
j'étais devenu un peu peut-être trop
intense dans toutes mes aventures et pas
mal de aussi de mes aventures
il ya eu des moments où un peu plus
trouble ou peut-être ça va vous paraître
un peu trop romanesque au cliché mais
regarder vers le ciel
surtout qu'on est au sommet de ces
beaufs top de building et ce qui m'a
fait garder les pieds sur terre dans le
fond c'est mon histoire familiale alors
en 1975
mes parents ont dû partir du cambodge à
cause de la guerre puis sont arrivés en
france là où je suis né puis ensuite à
montréal là où j'ai grandi dedans cette
chance énorme d'avoir une triple
identité et en 2012
j'ai donc décidé de retourner au
cambodge parce que j'avais cette envie
de justement retrouver retrouver mes
racines de réapprendre le coma et le
cambodgien et surtout de rencontrer la
nouvelle génération mais encore plus
j'avais cette envie de peindre
parce que je savais que par rapport à
mes voyages précédents qui étaient
purement familiaux que le cambodge et
était rempli de murs murs vierge les
mieux remplis de texture est imprégné
d'histoire
alors en 2012 il ya deux ans j'ai eu la
chance d'y retourner avec accompagné de
mes grands amis du grand ami réalisateur
et on est parti sur cette idée ou de
faire un projet documentaire un long
métrage qui s'intitule de loudes semaine
donc je conviens juge d'ailleurs de
terminer et qu'on est sur la
finalisation de la petite protégée igp
production donc je vais vous montrer le
petit teaser qu'on avait lancé le
cambodge
le cambodge comme une mère un jour elle
tomba malade souffrante mourante
elle pouvait plus prendre soin de ses
enfants
du haut de ses papiers partez
grandissent et apprenez je m'excuse de
ne pas pouvoir prendre soin de vous je
m'excuse je m'excuse de ne pas être en
position de prendre soin de vous
présentement à jour
je vois perdu
hélas aujourd'hui en ce moment précis
elle nous rappelle
cette et reviennent vous vous trouvez
plus que nécessaire combat je le rappel
de toutes les façons possibles et
inimaginaux
pendant ce temps de l'autre elle guérit
les deux photos partie de cette guérison
et donc en atterrissant au cambodge
je voulais pas tout de suite pas namur
j'avais besoin de partir un petit
pèlerinage dans ses fabuleuses la
fabuleuse cité dans le corps donc j'y
suis retourné comme un petit moine pour
y étudier le style cobaye le style
cobayes qui est en fond les ornements
les ornements qu'on retrouve gravé sur
les murs là bas et puis c'est à ce
moment-là que j'ai comme une
illumination
j'étais complètement ébloui par devant
cette richesse de forme cet héritage
ancestral et dorée tout le symbolisme
derrière chaque élément gravé et puis
même si entre 1975 et 79 sur le régime
khmer rouge tous les intellectuels les
artistes
bref toute notre culture a été
complètement éradiquée eh bien j'avais
l'impression que ces temples est encore
là pour une raison
même après plus de 1000 ans est témoin
de tellement de guerre de bataille et de
souffrance je sais pas c'est peut-être
mais gêne encore rien qu'ils sont mis à
se manifester en disant on vient de là
je viens de là donc par conséquent on se
doit de s'élever et puis on n'a pas
besoin de retourner si loin dans le
passé
si on regarde dans les années 60 le
cambodge c'était l'âge d'or la culture
c'était l'art la musique la danse et
aujourd'hui encore trop peu de commun
son courant de tout ce passé glorieux et
puis en même temps c'est normal puisque
les trente dernières années on était
repassé à retrouver rafistolé repro
pagès qui avait été perdu mais imaginez
vous si on pouvait assister justement un
retour de cet âge d'or
un retour de ce grand empire que fut
cambodge un genre de mayom pas le strike
back
et puis je vous avoue c'est ça que j'ai
pu constater durant mes derniers voyages
j'ai pu voir les signes de ce que
j'espère devenir une révolution par
l'art une révolution artistique
bref pour revenir à mon petit pèlerinage
je suis revenu dans la capitale à phnom
penh et j'ai décidé donc de mélanger ma
structure traditionnelle de graffitis de
mon petit lettrage avec l'esthétique
cobayes puis à ce moment là j'étais tout
excité je commençais à peine né pour la
première fois je me sentais accompli je
me dis ouah je m'entraîne pas le premier
graffiti lettrage pailleté style
cambodgien donc mon fond qui ego de
super héros étaient tous flatter tout
pompé et puis ce qui s'est passé c'est
que après avoir fait ce métrage qui se
retrouvaient en fait devant la une des
rues principales de la capitale devant
le bureau des premiers ministres la
chambre des ministres eh bien il s'est
fait face et après même pas une semaine
bon j'étais pas trop fâché parce qu'en
même temps le graffiti le graffiti est
éphémère et je voulais faire cette
esthétique parce que le graffiti en fait
est l'un des plus grands mouvements de
toute l'histoire de l'art pour ne pas
dire le plus grand mouvement parce qu'il
est partie de sa jeunesse
et partout où le graffiti s'est propagé
à une vitesse fulgurante
le graffiti est le miroir de la société
de la ville ou du pays dans lequel ils
se développent
d'où le fait que je voulais vraiment
créer une esthétique à saveur purement
cambodgienne et donc j'ai appris en
peignant dans cet endroit
qu'en fait je me retrouvais à l'entrée
d'un bidonville
ce bidonville qui en fait l'entrée d'un
lac on appelait bangkok lac bangkok où
il ya quelques années il n'y a pas si
longtemps de ça une compagnie privée a
décidé de racheter les terres et puis de
le remplir de sable et d'expulser ses
habitants pour y construire une méga
cités histoire classique de notre époque
donc pour moi ça a été un gros reality
check
d'où le fait que je pouvais pas vraiment
être fâché qu'il soit fait face et même
s'il ya quelques mois quand j'y suis
retourné en durant l'hiver j'ai décidé
de retourner sur le même spot et de leur
peine en version un peu plus évolué mais
ce qui était le plus important pour moi
c'est vraiment toutes ces rencontres que
j'ai pu faire avec les gens de la
communauté et voir la réalité une télé
réalité du cambodge de voir par exemple
ces dames tout contente que je vire
peine sa maison bon après l'été un peu
plus fâchés mais bref
et on m'a dit que le cambodge et j'ai pu
constater que cambodge et en pleine
croissance économique ce qui est vrai
j'ai pu voir des nouveaux gratte-ciels
quelques gratte-ciel en pleine
construction
il faut savoir aussi que 80 % de la
population vit à la campagne
donc avec mes grands amis réalisateurs
on a décidé de partir sur l'île de coron
serein dans un petit village d'une
cinquantaine de familles de pêcheurs
et puis on a décidé d'y aller pour
donner du matériel scolaire aux jeunes
donner des ateliers et en m'assurant de
toujours laisser une petite marque de
mon passage sur leur petite école et
ensuite il ya quelques mois j'y suis
encore retourner cette fois pour suivre
ma chère mu qui était de retour aussi au
cambodge pour pour donner des ateliers
mais avec une quantité beaucoup plus
importante de matériel ce qui nous a
permis d'aller dans plus d'écoles reculé
dans la campagne continue à donner des
ateliers et encore une fois laisser une
petite trace de mon passage sur leur
école et puis durant ces ateliers ya
beaucoup de d'enfants qui misait pour
comme au caire cours ce qui veut dire
je sais pas comment dessiner j'étais
choquée je sais pas pour vous mais pour
moi un enfant de 3 à 5 ans qui me disent
je sais pas dessiner
j'aurais compris s'il m'avait dit je
sais pas quoi dessiner mais pas dessiner
je veux dire habituellement que l'on
redonne un crayon un papier puis vont se
mettre instinctivement à gribouiller ou
peut-être c'était juste moi il ya une
étude qui a été faite au québec où il
est dit que les jeunes qui ont eu la
chance d'avoir des cours d'art durant
leur jeunesse ont tendance à moins
décrocher de l'école que ceux qui n'ont
pas eu du tout je sais que c'est un
contexte complètement différent le
cambodge du québec mais là où je veux en
venir c'est que l'art est primordial
pour le développement d'un enfant au
lieu d'aller à l'école et d'exécuter ce
qu'on lui dit de faire pour une fois il
peut s'exprimer et saissac la jeunesse
cnj a besoin et c'est ça qu'elle veut
elle veut s'exprimer parce que pendant
tellement d'années
le cambodge a été refermé tellement
d'émotions été refoulés sachant encore
que à cause du génocide 70% de la
population est en dessous de 30 ans donc
ce qui fait un pays incroyablement
dynamique des jeunes qui ont soif de
modernité parce qu'ils ont ils en ont
pas vraiment ils n'ont pas de temps
accès il commence mais ils ont soif de
modernité et puis en même temps cette
attitude a des bons comme des mauvais
côtés
la mauvais côté si on généralise la
plupart des cas et vivent constamment
dans ce sentiment d'insécurité
ils se disent que par exemple si on
vient au canada en europe en amérique on
viendra riche et on souffrira plus
jamais et puis ce qui ce qui est
compréhensible parce qu'il ya tellement
de gens qui sont encore en mode survie
là bas même s'il ya une classe moyenne
qui est en train de se développer
et puis aussi à toute cette influence
externe par exemple l influence de la
pop coréenne coacher la culture coréenne
pop ou des mecs comme justin bieber et
puis des fois sacré d espèce de parodie
de parodie mais en même temps j'ai
rencontré des gens incroyables sur place
des cas et des cambodgiens locaux ou de
la diaspora qui sont venus et qui ont
décidé de se réapproprier notre culture
de par exemple à celui qui a ramené le
hip hop il m'a ramené aux racines du hip
hop est une culture que j'adore où il a
fait renaître les vieux sont des années
60 et a mis un petit bip durable
permettant à des jeunes de s'exprimer
plein de gens incroyables qu'on retrouve
dans le documentaire de lucho mais qui
ont créé des voies pour permettre aux
jeunes de s'exprimer de grandir et de
s'épanouir à travers l'art la musique la
danse
alors imaginez l'impact de l'art dans un
pays où les gens sont tellement
artistique où il ya cette richesse
devant eux
ce qui m'amène à vous montrer cette
murale ici qui est avait réalisé en 2012
donc aussi à deux ans s'intitule rajoute
des couleurs aux présents citons passé
de sang bleu gris qui était ma petite
maxime qui m'a conduit durant tout ce
voyage je vais vous présenter à gauche
à votre gauche mon grand père qui est le
père de ma mère et le couple en hausse
et les parents de mon père qui tous les
trois j'ai jamais connu ils sont morts
ou ont disparu durant le génocide
et puis à droite ce belles au monde tout
en blanc c'est mon arrière grand père
que j'ai eu la chance de connaître et
qui a vécu tous les génocides avec mon
ami grand-mère et avec toute la famille
on se retrouve et justement pour
célébrer les 10 ans de
de son décès il était en 2002 et puis je
me suis posé la question comment ça se
fait qu'il ait pu survivre tous les
génocides avec mon arrière grand mère
étant donné que c'était des
intellectuels et il travaille pour le
gouvernement
parce que mon arrêt grand père faisait
partie de la première génération de
forestiers à avec la plantation d'hévéas
pour le caoutchouc
donc j'ai demandé à mon arrière grand
mère qui était encore qui est encore
vivante en fait même si elle dit
toujours je vais peut-être partir j'ai
peut-être mourir demain un peu moins
depuis que mon grand frère l'a dit
attends qu exane est peut-être tu seras
arrière-arrière-grand-mère et bref je
lui ai demandé et puis elle m'a dit que
lorsqu'il ya eu d'exode rural avec
l'entrée des khmers rouges dans la
capitale
ils ont marché vers l'implantation et
puis là tous les jambes les enfants
comme les adultes étaient devenus
communs et rouge
mais du fait que mes arrière grands
parents ont toujours été très proche du
peuple généreux sincère et honnête et
bien ce sont ces mêmes gens qui les ont
protégés et cacher leur identité durant
ses quatre années d'horreur je trouvais
pas c'est incroyable tout cas moi ça m'a
ça m'a fait penser que si on mène une
vie pure honnête et sincère c'est plus
fort que toute idéologie poussait à
l'extrême où toute guerre et puis oui
c'est ma famille que j'ai peint sur ce
mur mais avant tout ce sont des khmers
avec ce sourire
typiquement commun et puis chaque
personne que vous allez rencontrer
quelques combos jen a perdu au moins une
personne de sa famille durant le
génocide mais chaque histoire de famille
est unique et ce sont toutes ces
histoires uniques rassembler ensemble
qui crée l'histoire du cambodge avec un
grand h
et puis durant les trente dernières
années le cambodge commence justement à
les gens commencent à parler après ces
trente années de silence
quelqu'un a dit qu'un un peuple sans
mémoire est un peuple sans avenir
et puis j'ai eu donc ben en même temps
je pense qu'il ya cette opportunité
aujourd'hui injustement reconstruire le
cambodge mais basée sur les valeurs de
nos ancêtres parce que tout va si vite
tout aussi vite maintenant j'ai eu la
chance durant ces
deux dernières années de retourner au
cambodge et puis de collaborer avec
beaucoup d'artistes locaux de faire des
expositions et de peines beaucoup de
murs rassemblant tellement d'histoires
de vie partagent en plein de l'histoire
et des histoires qui m'ont tellement
inspiré pour que je les partage un peu
avec vous aujourd'hui
alors je me dis que si on pouvait
justement par l'art ne serait-ce qu
apaisé ou soigner justement les plaies
de nos parents nos propres plaît je me
dis qu'on pourrait transformer qu'on
pourrait transformer un des pires
moments de l'histoire ont un des plus
beaux peut-être à suivre merci